has this ever happen to you are you  peeing on me yeah but what are you gonna  do buddy nothing he's right of course of  course it has but no more  with this new PewDiePie backpack you are  fully protected  just watch the results go and buy your  footie PI backpack link in the  description hurry before they run out  all right  wasn't that great in case you didn't get  it you can now buy the awesome  PewDiePie backpacks check out the link  in the description it doesn't look too  big but it actually has a lot of space  for stuff let's see what we have in here  I'm a buck um let's see here oh we have  a good tour what smog what are you doing  here somehow skateboard Maya were you  doing in the back bag huh weird oh vent  your time hat okay Oh My look in for my  glasses so yeah it's pretty amazing  brofist is included for free here it  comes  broke I don't know what I'm doing